>> WELCOME BACK TO AMERICAN
NINJA WARRIOR.
>> YOU KNOW IT.
COMING UP NEXT IS A COMPETITOR
WITH A VERY MOVING STORY.
>> HI, I'M JEFF METCALF, 42
YEARS OLD FROM BEASLEY, TEXAS.
WELL IT USED TO BE BEAUTIFUL
BEFORE THE TORNADO.
THE TORNADO LEVELED EVERYTHING.
PEOPLE LOST THEIR HOMES.
THAT'S WHEN I DECIDED I HAD TO
DO SOMETHING.
USED THE SCRAP OF WOODS FROM MY
HOUSE AND BUILT AN OBSTACLE
COURSE.
SHOW THE PEOPLE OF BEASLEY, IF
THE CHIPS ARE DOWN.
YOU WORK HARD AND PUT YOUR MIND
TO IT.
ANYTHING IS POSSIBLE.
>> WOW, JEFF, YOU HAVE BEEN
THROUGH A LOT.
>> THIS ISN'T ABOUT ME.
I'M DOING IT FOR THE PEOPLE OF
BEASLEY.
>> I SEE SOME OF YOUR FRIEND AND
NEIGHBORS ARE HERE TONIGHT TO
CHEER YOU ON.
>> YEAH, THERE THEY ARE.
THERE IS MY PEEPS, HEY, GUYS!
>> LET'S GO!
>> OKAY, JEFF, ARE YOU READY.
>> I AM NO LONGER JEFF MET CALF.
I AM CAPTAIN TORNADO.
I AM DOING THIS FOR MY TOWN.
>> OKAY, CAPTAIN TORNADO, GO GET
THEM.
AS THE A REMINDER HE WILL HAVE
TO BEAT SAM'S TIME FOR THE
QUALIFYING ROUND.
>> THAT'S RIGHT.
HOW HAVE YOU BEEN BY THE WAY.
>> I'M DEPRESSED.
NO REASON REALLY.
YOU HIDE IT GREAT.
LET'S SEE IF CAPTAIN TORNADO
WILL BE OUR NEXT AMERICAN NINJA
WARRIOR.
AND HE IS OFF.
AND IT'S OVER FOR CAPTAIN
TORNADO.
>> THAT WAS NOT A GOOD OUTING
FOR JEFF.
>> LET'S TAKE A LOOK AT THE
SLOW-MO.
HE COMPLETELY MISJUDGED WHERE
THAT FIRST PAD WAS.
>> AS IF THERE WAS ABSOLUTELY NO
COMMUNICATION BETWEEN HIS BRAIN
AND BODY.
>> NOW LET'S TAKE A LOOK AT THE
REACTION OF HIS FANS.
IF YOU WATCH CLOSELY YOU CAN SEE
THE HOPE SLOWLY DRAINING FROM
THEIR FACES.
>> I MEAN ANY RESPECT THAT THEY
HAD FOR JEFF HAS NOW COMPLETELY
VANISHED THAT'S GOT TO SUCK FOR
THEM.
THEY PUT THEIR EGGS IN THE WRONG
BASKET.
>> ABSOLUTELY.
ALL RIGHT, JEFF, SO WHAT DO YOU
THINK HAPPENED OUT THERE.
>> I DID BAD.
I FELL DOWN.
>> YOU SURE DID.
>> BUT JEFF, BECAUSE WE WERE SO
MOVED BY YOUR STORY, WE HAVE A
LITTLE SURPRISE FOR YOU.
WE DECIDED TO GIVE YOU A SPECIAL
AMERICAN NINJA DO OVER.
>> REALLY?
>> THAT'S RIGHT.
>> SO USE WHAT YOU HAVE LEARNED
ON YOUR FIRST RUN.
APPLY IT TO THIS ONE.
>> I WILL.
I'VE WON'T LET YOU DOWN THIS
TIME THE I WILL DO IT FOR
BEASLEY.
>> YOU HAVE GOT THIS JEFF.
>> I KNOW.
HE IS FOCUSING UP.
>> LOOK AT INTENSITY ON HIS
FACE.
>> HE IS NOT GOING TO LET THE
RARE SECOND CHANCE SLIP AWAY.
OH.
HE BLEW IT AGAIN.
>> ALL MOST HAS IF HEART IS IN
THE RIGHT PLACE BUT HIS BODY IS
ABSOLUTE JUNK.
>> MAYBE NAMING YOURSELF AFTER
THE THING THAT DESTROYED YOUR
DOWN WASN'T THE BEST CHOICE.
>> LOT'S LOOK AT THE SLOW-MO.
I EXPECTED HIM TO LOOK A LITTLE
MORE DISAPPOINTED.
I MEAN HEAP ALMOST LOOKS HAPPY.
>> HATE TO SAY IT BUT I THINK
THAT IS AN I'M PEEING FACE.
AND HERE HE COMES.
STRUGGLING UP THE STAGE.
JEFF, HOW DID THAT FEEL?
>> NOT GOOD.
>> ARE YOU EMBARRASSED?
>> DO-OVER.
I WAS NOT READY.
MY SHOES ARE WET.
THINK THAT THING IS BROKEN.
>> NO, JEFF, UNFORTUNATELY WE
DON'T HAVE TIME.
SORRY.
>> I HAVE HOW TO DO THIS FOR MY
PEEPS, SORRY.
>> THEY'RE LONG GONE, JEFF.
THEY'RE OUT OF HERE.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> I DON'T CARE.
I HAVE GOT TO DO THIS.
I AM DOING THIS FOR BEASLEY.
>> WOW, HE JUST TRIED TO RUN
ACROSS THE WATER.
>> WHAT A DUDE.
JUST A REMINDER HE DID THIS FOR
HIS TOWN.
>> HEAP LOST HIS DIGNITY AND
LOST HIS PANTS.
>> THE TORNADO DESTROYED THE
HOME.
BUT THIS TORNADO DESTROYED THEIR
SPIRIT AND SHOWED ITS PENIS.
WE'LL BE RIGHT BACK WITH MORE
AMERICAN NINJA WARRIOR.
[ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]